he moves you anyway can't do all of them
yeah so just yeah just pick one
calculate you and you now you see that
even the white king was forced to the
first rank i mean if white's king is for
forced to the first rank then there is
just absolutely nothing to talk about
okay you go g2 and then again this king
activity
okay look have to look forward to rook
f3 that's a nice one peter and i don't
really see a way for white to actually
hold on from trading the rooks or keep
upon he's going to end up either trading
or losing one of the pawns i'm just
expecting actually jordan to throw in
the towel here yes yes that's it and he
does it
he does it and with that prague wins the
first game of their four game match what
an incredible start with the black
pieces uh quite an exciting game this
was peter taken off guard with jordan's
offbeat idea but keeping cool calm and
his composure and then that rookie force
suddenly it was all a prague game
winning that g4 pawn
yeah well i think that jordan is not
very very